Hắn thông tấn chư tiên Casi Nga ngày hâm sau thân năm 2019, chư tiên đã bắt giữ thêm một quan trực,
liên quan đến sự gố hạ thui tâu khu chục hại quân năm nhìn tấn,
sảy ra để thành phố cảnh Trung Jinh, không hành mốt hình nằm.
Nguyễn bị bắt là ông Vee, yung sân, phó khu chừng cục công nghiệp đạn dựu của đàn lo động chư tiên.
Theo Casi Nga, ông Vee bị khá vụ chữ trưng nhập lớn cho buộc việc.
Chư đó, bà người khác đã bị bắt giữ, gồm kỹ sư trường nhà máy động tạo Trung Jinh,
chương dựng đóng thân tạo và phó giống đó phủ chắc khảy chính,
tâu khu chục miễn nghe giống mất cân bằng kỹ hạ thui,
dạ đến tại tạo biến dạng và nước tràn vào khoan đôi,
công tắc khối phục hiện đang đự tiên hành, giữ sự chí đạo của nhóm chuyên dạng.
Casi Nga cũng cho biết, sẽ mất khoảng 2 đến 3 ngày để bâng hết nước,
bà người ngày để sự thân tạo.
Nha lãnh đạo kìm trưng gọi sự cố này là hành vý phạm tội không thể chếm nhận được,
nhấn mạnh cuối tâm sự liên nghiêm các khá nhìn quan,
và chúng lại tình trạng khí chính nghiệp trong công tắc cơm yếu cố phòng.